And apps. So this weekend is
Darren till versus Wonderboy.
Excuse me, versus Tyron Woodley.
Why don't I say versus Wonderboy?
We'll kind of flip was that,
and you know why?
Cause it was reading a article of
this really interesting article about
Wonderboy and his last three fights,
the two fights with Tyron Woodley
that were super duper close.
And then one fight with Darren
till that was also really close.
And they were talking about like how,
um, if you looked at it on paper,
the people from outside,
I think they were there were
saying that global scorecard,
I think that's how they're describing it,
meaning how people scored it,
like on average around the world.
Uh,
more people gave it to Wonderboy
then gave it to Darren till.
And the same thing happened with,
um, the Tyron Woodley fights.
I feel like the decisions were
right in all those fights.
I feel like I'm in the woods. He fights
in particular with the hurt Wonderboy.
Wonderboy didn't really hurt with the, I
think that counts for more. It just does.
Woodley, Tyron Woodley had him out.
I mean, he had, I'm really hurt.
And Wonderboy never had Tyron in that
kind of trouble in either one of those
fights.
So I would,
I would give that advantage clearly to
tire and I would think that if he lost
that fight that wouldn't
make it any sense.
Cause fights are supposed to be
about who does the most damage,
who of WHO's more effective. I mean
Wonderboy was effective for more time,
but that's just like movement
and sticking and hitting him,
hitting him with small shots.
But tyrin put him on, you know,
unconsciousness his door. He was like
right there. It was very dangerous.
It was way different. And plus you got the
impact. Yeah. I said, well I don't know.
I'm not sure. I believe that. I think, you
know, if someone really wins a decision,
they really wanted decision,
but it's just what's most
important is damage. If you,
you guys are basically
in a striking exchange.
We're not talking about like submission
attempts versus striking exchanges.
Like which one's better? He almost
had him choked out with that triangle.
Well he almost had them
knocked out that left hook.
We're not talking about that because it
was basically just a striking match and
in just as plain old striking match,
Willie was the one who landed
the biggest shots in my mind.
We've got to figure out a way to quantify
that. It just doesn't make any sense.
Well, you could see a guy having
a guy fucked up and almost out to,
I think the same way about the
Robert Whitaker Yoel Romero fight.
There's two rounds in that fight where
Yoel Romero is land in bombs on Whitaker.
Whitaker is hurt bad. How does he lose
that fight? I don't understand that.
It doesn't make, to me, even if it makes
sense in the current scoring system,
that scoring system is fucking flawed.
That shit doesn't make any sense.
Like logically when you're
looking at what is the,
what's the ultimate goal of fighting.
But if you look at those three fights,
just at least on paper,
Wonderboy is like right up there and
Darren till with one fight with cowboy one
fight with him.
Those two fights with their most
high profile fights of his career.
Boom already got a title shot. It's
really interesting. That's how,
that's how talented Darren Tillis people
are so interested in him. 17 to know.
25 years old, they're like,
fuck, give him a chance.
The real battle for this guy
almost is not just the fight,
which is going to be of course a battle,
but making 170 and how much
longer does he do that? He's,
I mean he fucking,
he's hurting to get down to one 70
apparently he was at one 82 yes,
he's giant dude. Giant. You'll see
how much bigger he is in Woodley.
This is the video at the press conference
when I stand next to each other.
And how tall is it till puts his
hands over his head. I can't tell.
It says inches.
He's gotta be six too.
But he said a big giant six to six
foot either. That's just six foot,
even 72 inches. That's right. It
is. He seems way taller than that.
Yeah, watch the go to the
video of them. That's crazy.
Why don't think he was six
to, anyway, just still,
we're talking one 70 his clearly taller.
He's a big fucker too.
It's not just tall. He's
thick. You know, he's a,
he's a big fucking guy and he has
a hard time making that weight.
Look how fucking big is dude.
Seriously.
That looks like more than three inches.
Unless he's wearing some crazy
cowboy boots on and, no, but look,
it's going to be hard to do anything
that Woodley man. Very hard. Hard. Well,
there's a bunch of things with
wood and the, first of all,
the fucking speed you're
dealing with speed that you,
you probably haven't seen before.
Exactly. And that his level of wrestling,
look at these two guys he
doesn't want to listen to, isn't,
there's no submitting until, I
mean, he knows Jujitsu for sure.
He lived in Brazil for a few
years. He actually speaks,
speaks Portuguese. Oh Shit.
Okay. Yeah. Um, he got stabbed
in London and then, uh,
went to Brazil to fucking recoup and hi
and hang out and lived there for awhile.
I don't know the full story of it,
but he speaks perfect Portuguese
after one of his fights in Brazil,
he addressed the crowd in Portuguese,
was pretty crazy.